the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night pass
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to start every
episode like I start every episode this
one's no different thank you very much
for your support I cannot thank you guys
enough man you really
I all the messages I get I start my sets
like this too I'm beyond Blown Away by
how this show helps so many people I had
no idea I get it now and I want you to
genuinely know you're doing the same
thing for me so thank you very much all
right if you are watching right now
please hit that subscribe button it's a
free way to help the show uh if you
gotta have more you then you gotta check
out the patreon I'll never stop telling
you about it it is the Honeydew with
y'all and I highlight the low lights
with you all and y'all have the wildest
I've said it we just talked to a guy who
died for three and a half minutes
because a pickup truck pushed them down
in a in a foot and a half of water and
he couldn't get out and he died in his
friend's [ __ ] arms they're holding
his legs yeah and uh three and a half
minutes and they [ __ ] give them CPR
and bring the dude back to life it's
absolutely crazy it's five bucks a month
you sign up for your year you get over a
month free you get the Honeydew a day
early audio and video you get an ad free
and it's at no additional cost it's five
bucks all right now that's the biz you
guys know what we're doing over here
we're highlighting the low lights I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and I am very excited
to have this guest on here today first
time on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome George
strombolopolis welcome to the Honeydew
bro did I get it perfect man you nailed
it
listen it's more than most people can
say so I appreciate it thank you so much
for being here I'm happy to be here I
think what you do is really important
life is about showing other people
they're not alone and sometimes you
can't just say you're not alone
sometimes they have to pick up on that
themselves by hearing stories and
finding their way into it I think that
this podcast and your storytelling does
that dude thank you so much man
um I'm dying to talk to you but before
we do please plug promote everything and
anything you'd like I got a daily music
show on Apple music hits I uh which is
uh for free on your phone if you
subscribe to Apple music you can get me
on demand at a whole bunch of
documentaries and specials we do but um
yeah that's where I am Monday to Friday
uh about 165 countries around the world
and I love sharing music and telling
stories about the artists who make it I
gotta connect you do you know Josh out
of Myers only by name oh no yeah he does
a podcast called The 500 where he does
the Rolling Stones top 500 uh but he's a
musical comedian as well very
controversial list at 500. it's already
changed listen I said Josh that's a
10-year podcast
I'm like what are you doing now do you
stick to the whole list it's the 1000.
uh well thank you for being here
um but I really wanted to talk to you
about because you you saw the Gen X
thing I did with Christina yeah so you
just told me you before we came on you
turned 50. yeah so you're writing that
Gen X window right there I grew up in a
neighborhood in Toronto about your life
couple of different neighborhoods that
were what you would call the compromise
neighborhoods um I loved them growing up
uh first kid in my family born in Canada
immigrant family in a neighborhood of
immigrants it's uh it's the thing that I
identify the most with is my
neighborhoods more than even the city of
the country where's your family from so
my dad is born and that side of the
family are all from Egypt but they're
Greek descent and my mom's Ukrainian
born so strombolopolis Greek father you
got it and kept it totally and even
though I didn't even try to shorten it
or anything nah man you know my family
split up when I was seven my old man
split and when he left there are people
in my family that shortened the versions
of the name I think when my mom put me
into high school she had a shortened
version of the name strombols and I was
like no I ain't doing that
I couldn't spell it till I was in grade
five fifth grade I couldn't spell it
seriously I just I didn't know how to do
it I didn't think I'd ever need to 17.
17 it's a thing but I you know like I
said I come from a a city of in a
neighborhood of immigrants and I think
the ethnicity is a defining factor for
me and my Gen X friends what's the how
far does it get on a credit card it
doesn't always go so usually the last
couple of letters my very brief
non-illustrious stint in the military
they couldn't fit the whole thing in So
yeah so if there's different versions
yeah I like that you're like now this is
my [ __ ] hair and [ __ ] MasterCards
like that you're strong a lot so yeah
that's right when I started radio I went
to work in a small town in British
Columbia one of my first legal jobs in
radio and somebody said to me look you
got to change your name because that
ethnic stuff might fly in Toronto but it
doesn't work here and I couldn't come up
with a nickname I tried to confuse him
and call myself George Jefferson that
was gonna be my radio name okay thinking
they wouldn't catch on they caught on
yeah um and then they just go to call me
by my initials but as soon as I got to
Toronto I was like no no my name is
strombolopolis don't be afraid to
ethnicity let's roll with it so yeah
that's it but yeah your Gen X video made
me laugh and when I shared it on my
social medias the response to it was
huge and what I really loved was the
split a whole bunch of people were
vouching for it then a bunch of people
were saying that screwed us up and I'm
like that's your story didn't screw me
up I'm grateful for it they're like you
you all raised it no I didn't I had a
kid when I was 41. you know I mean I
don't even know what this generation my
daughter's right I didn't [ __ ] no
she'd be an alpha I guess your kid
generation would also called I think
their Alphas is that right I think
Alpha's starting over again I don't know
man that's a [ __ ] that's a slippery
slope to be naming kids that [ __ ] that's
gonna get to them no totally but I love
the thing because I I really did feel
like
what I was able to do as a kid my mom
encouraged it was with the go outside
thing was go go be bored and figure it
out yeah figure it out she didn't
endanger me I don't think they knew what
the city was but my mom I think was 19
or 20 when she had me she was a kid too
so they they were doing the best they
could the concept of the helicopter
parent was I knew kids who had that that
was not my life and you're right just
wandering in wandering out I'd go a week
sometimes I don't see my mom when I was
16 17 years old and I bump into her at
the bus stop she'd be like hey you ever
coming home I am love you good to see
you and I'll see you in a bit I was
working since I was 11 and
I I know that backfired for a lot of
people but it didn't backfire for me I'm
so grateful I'm I'm so durable and
resilient the hustle that it puts in you
instills in the work ethic that it's
still I also think that it's interesting
you said go figure it out I just it just
made me start thinking like how many
people don't have hobbies anymore yeah
you know you didn't we didn't have a
phone in our hand or anything you go
outside next thing you know you're
[ __ ] looking at butterflies or birds
or whatever really I [ __ ] like
butterflies or fishing or whatever
where's the fish I used to draw yeah you
had to go do something and I recognized
that that version of our childhood
um was probably very dangerous for a
bunch of people and I think we got lucky
a lot of us didn't make yeah well I just
didn't make a lot of jet acts out there
did not make totally and so I don't I
don't ever want to you know gloss over
how traumatic it was for people but what
I've always been raised to do is not
blame my parents or their parents or
their parents because they didn't have
access to the tools that everybody has
now it's really easy to sit back and say
my mom did this or my dad did this there
were kids in a system that was crushing
them jobs were going away all this stuff
or Vietnam at that time for my father's
age totally and and wave of immigrants
into Canada so I don't hold them
accountable for the stuff they didn't
have access to it's just I know other
people do and I wouldn't like you do
your thing but for me I would never do
it and also I just love the fact that
you said it and you left my favorite
part was try not to get kidnapped yeah
because that was actually a thing in
that molested arrested all the ads that
was the thing if you grew up in poor
neighborhoods that's where the
government would put the sex offenders
so it was a Dodge game to get from the
bus home when you're eight you were
running I had to run from people and
when you said it just brought back a
whole bunch of memories of should we be
playing baseball man in Sandlot Park in
Rexdale where I grew up and a van would
pull up on the grass oh in the Outfield
and we'd be like [ __ ] one yeah hell yeah
I never had yeah
yeah so I was like you know what man I
think it was all bad and I wish
everybody was raised differently but it
worked for me I'm grateful so yeah yeah
um all right let's jump back that you
said seven your dad left all right what
do you see him or you split custody or
he just don't bounce he bounced when I
was seven I was home I watched him leave
I think he said he was coming back your
only child not a younger sister she was
four so I don't think she really knew
what was happening so much but you're
watching him what grab his [ __ ] and
walking I watched him put on a suit so
he wouldn't have to get wrinkled in
suitcase and put it he went out in a
suit in a pale blue suit like a 70s Arab
pale blue suit it looked Dope by the way
I was gonna say that is a hell of an egg
that's a sad beautiful
I was sitting on my front porch and I
watched him leave
um and that was it and then I think he
came back is it better that he left like
that than in like a wife beat or smoking
a cigarette
totally and it was a bit you know it's
one of those things where I watch myself
telling you though as he's saying hey
I'm leaving no he didn't but I knew I
mean I knew that there was some drama
with him and my mom and he was was your
mom there when he left I don't think she
was or at least you don't remember I
don't remember she might have been in
the house I'm just like I'm out and that
was it who's it man so I saw him I think
I've seen him
maybe four or five times in the 42 years
since you left yeah yeah so when when
was the first time from seven to when
was the first time I think he came back
I don't remember exactly but I think he
came back roughly when I was 11. for
them to finalize the divorce then I
didn't see him again until maybe I was
18 then I saw him once in mind was that
like do you remember
I mean you're yeah technically a man at
that point right of your own you know
what it was in the last that first time
I saw him and the last time I saw him
both happened the exact same way I he
moved to the states he moved to Florida
so I just happened to go to Florida and
I thought God I think my dad lives near
here so I found out where my dad lived
and I just showed up to say hey yeah
yeah what was that like he wasn't home
but his wife was freaked and she said
wow do you look just like him no I look
young and tough and she thought I was
there to get her sons
she's like she wouldn't open the door
and I said I'm uh I'm I'm my dad Mark
I'm Mark's kid and she got really shaken
she said he's gonna be at the bowling
alley tonight and I'm like all right
I'll show up there so I bumped into him
there he got freaked out you were coming
no problem
yeah yeah and much respect to her for
that that's interesting she didn't tell
him uh and then the last time I saw him
the same thing happened um but I feel
badly for my dad because he didn't know
what I did for a living so he doesn't
know what I look like so he told me that
he was watching a TV show that I was the
host of and he saw my name on it and
he's like that's so weird that's my
dad's name because I'm named after my
grandfather the Greek tradition and uh
he didn't even know what you look like
you know it looked like he saw his son
on TV and was like oh we have that name
totally get the [ __ ] yeah yeah which
is a trip for him that's what he told me
and then again I saw him years later
actually some maybe five or so I can't I
think that might have been the last time
I saw him and I just happened to be in
Florida and I walked by him and he knew
I was coming
and I said hey man and he's like hey how
you doing and you walk by me because he
doesn't know what I look like I had a
big beard so it's harder for him than it
is in fact it was never hard for me and
this is what I'm super grateful like my
mom's a g like my mom is like that that
kind of person that you think if you
were ever going to be born into a rough
situation you need that kind of mom I
had that Mom she told me when I was
seven you will never grow up with daddy
issues she used that phrase she said it
doesn't matter that he's gone the
Cavalry ain't coming people can love you
and leave it's complicated
um it's not his fault damn your mom told
you people can love you and leave it's
complicated yeah that's [ __ ] great
advice dude my mom my mom did it gave me
chills yeah she really like saved my
life I wish somebody would have told me
that before she did I grew up with no
sense yeah but also when no one tells
you that that is a you think that like
what the [ __ ] they just go yeah like
well yeah that's what happens no one
gives you a heads up no and she said the
Cavalry ain't coming this is this is it
right and I thought but the thing my mom
did was lead with love and I think
that's the thing I learned through all
the weird and crazy traumatic things and
good things in my life is that what
really mattered is love and your job is
irrelevant I I don't even remember any
time in my life and you are not your job
not at all yeah I don't even think
anybody in my family ever asked what I
wanted to do for a living that I can
recall because in my family we got jobs
my grandmother wanted me to be a bus
driver we don't have careers that's not
the world I come from so the fact that
this is my career and I got so lucky to
be here with you and do the things I've
been able to do my family never really
valued that they valued what kind of
kind of man will you grow up to be and
I've tried to honor it got it wrong a
bunch of times but I've tried to be the
guy that they wanted and I'm grateful
for my mom did a lot of that little [ __ ]
that was your mom was mom and dad then
my mom it's interesting that she's
stepping outside of her motherly nature
and giving you some Eternal [ __ ] too
like young like a towel I think when my
dad split my mom's 24 25
she had she was a cocktail waitress she
had no education she was the I'd only
been in the country for like 10 years
um she maybe a little longer she figured
it out I had a great family like my
grandmother my uncle my aunt were epic
and those were her family her family
yeah and everybody we did what those
families did he just come together and
family was above all family was above
all and how you treat people was a
bubble I remember man my mom because I
lived in a pretty rough neighborhood my
mom saw me going down the wrong path she
would write a poem on the back of a
movie poster I worked at a movie theater
so she'd write a poem on the back of a
movie poster that I'd taken from the
theater stuck it on the back of my front
door of my house and wouldn't let me
leave the house she put her arm around
me and she'd say say it out loud
say it out loud and I'd have to repeat
the poem Every time I left them or some
of it I have to live with myself and so
I have to live myself and what I have to
live with myself and so I want to be fit
for myself to know I have to sit with
the Setting Sun and not hate myself for
things I have done I want to watch as
the days go by and be able to look the
world straight in the eye dude damn
pre-teen teen young man [ __ ] Legend
dude my mom's a legend and so not
boohooing about this man that left or
just being like hey this is life and now
I saw her when he first left I saw how
scared my mom I'm sure I saw her cry and
I remember what you didn't see was her
cave break and collapse you saw her rise
up and rise up dude yeah my mom's a g
and what could what more could you ask
for total parent totally that's why I
kind of look around and people go oh you
don't have a dad I'm like dude I didn't
need one and I have no ill will towards
my Pops I hope he's Grand yeah I wanted
to go back to that real quick so 18 and
and he sees you in a bowling alley or
whatever what is that like dude what do
you ask you sit down and ask him
questions are you no but you're
comfortable enough what Mom mom's giving
you and the love that you don't need to
be like why did you leave or any it's
nothing like that never just sort of
picking up where you are at that moment
yeah how are you right how are you I'm
good tell me about your life a little
bit what are you doing cool great very
chill and what was he what job was he
what do you do I don't even know what he
did he was he worked on the Ford
assembly line it's kind of why I look at
with my dad with a generous heart
because he was a young guy two kids
working the Ford assembly line he looked
down the road his dad worked on the Ford
assembly line plant that was my future
and I think he probably just got freaked
he's like this is my life and he
probably panicked do you have any other
does he have any other children that are
half siblings or anything here's the
weird part about this so when he left my
family and he went down to raise a
family he had three sons that were my
age so he ended up just transferring one
family for another he got stepson he had
stepson said he had to raise at the same
time yeah so he didn't get out of being
yeah no he didn't get out of being a dad
and that never bothered you that he went
and did that with some other kids and
not you guys I don't know if it's
conditioning or my wiring but I've never
required closure and I've never valued
forgiveness for the sake of it
forgiveness usually is just something to
make that person feel better I don't
require it my whole thing is if you're
going to make a choice
own it I'm cool with it I just don't
have the wiring to worry I think it's
because I think life's so short I just
don't want to have I don't want anything
to have any power over me which is
probably how I compartmentalized when I
was a kid I kind of went oh if this is
out of my control what I can control is
my way through it right right it's
interesting to say that about the
Forgiveness because I what I know now
was a mistake it was around 2006 and my
mother had like abandoned our family and
we hadn't talked in years and I decided
that it was time to just call this
person and say I forgive you
um which I did
and it did nothing for you for any it
didn't move the needle in one way and
then I really had to think about and I
was like
huh and I had a therapist tell me one
time you can't give forgiveness to
someone who isn't asking for it yeah
they don't even they're like forgive me
for what right
and I realized that it was what I was
doing without realizing it was that was
for me yeah that was for me totally and
it did nothing for another
10 12 10 years another 10 years before
we really started talking but that was
all because I had a daughter right and
that's what brought that about but I did
realize that I was like you just tried
to forgive someone it doesn't dude they
probably don't even think they did
anything wrong
but wait so she was like okay were you
raised by your old man or another up
until we were 16 and then he died so
after that it was nobody bro yeah that's
a that's what I'm saying that whole Gen
X thing my dad was the same way my dad's
like I'm not always going to be here I'm
working a double tonight figure out how
to cook for yourself take care of you I
showed you how to do the grill make sure
that grass is cut when I come home I
showed you how to do the lawnmower don't
[ __ ] this [ __ ] up my mom taught me how
to darn a sock how to cook how to change
the oil harness yeah like get a hole in
your sock instead of going by now it's
actually taught me how to fix the hole
she taught me how to change oil in my
car how to change tires when I was young
my mom taught you how to [ __ ] change
oil rotation
she taught me how to cook she taught me
how to dance she said yeah we were
cooking and she would put um she put a
song on I was like like 10 she put a
song in the Boombox while we were
waiting for the water to boil she would
teach me how to dance she said so
somebody could dance with me at a
wedding like we would just have like she
taught me all these things but you know
what she taught me more is the things
she didn't know she was doing I watched
her get up at five o'clock in the
morning to her first job was to deliver
a newspaper so I would help her put the
newspapers together she would then come
home from that we'd have breakfast I'd
go to school with my sister she would
then go and work at a shitty greasy
spoon Greek restaurant where the men
were harassing her and being awful but
she would do it then she would come back
for lunch and then she would put herself
through nursing college to try to get to
become a nurse as assistant
um all three doing this all at the same
time and we were living in a rooming
house because to make ends meet we had a
home she rented out all the rooms in the
home so my sister and her and I shared
one or two rooms as we grew up
so I grew up around all these strangers
uh what was that like dope because I was
always growing up learning about other
people's lives and I think one of the
big things that gets people in trouble
I'm not a doctor so I don't know but
what I anecdotally what I think [ __ ]
people up is not life but life versus
expectations
so I never grew up thinking
I was in a tough spot yeah you lived in
a rooming house what I what I thought
growing up was you do what you got to do
to make it work so I never walked around
thinking I was poor I knew I was growing
up I remember watching a news story with
my mom one night saying they were
talking about what the poverty line was
the poverty line was like the household
income was fifteen thousand dollars a
year for a family
and I said to my mom how much do we
what's our household income and she told
me the number and it was way under that
and I went oh so like we're way below
the poverty line she says yeah but do
you feel it right and I said no she says
because What You Need Is Love
community and also we figure it out and
so I watched my mother
teach me at a very young age not through
lessons but really through actions which
is it doesn't matter what happens to you
it sucks
and you can choose to focus on that or
we can figure it out and because the
system isn't going to be there for you
now I grew up to think I'm going to
fight to try to change the system so
that the people grow after us don't have
to deal with the [ __ ] we did but at
the same time I'm grateful that it was
basically raised to be a warrior she my
mom didn't know she's a peace loving
woman she didn't she's a hardcore
Christian of which I'm not and she
raised me to be a warrior so more
importantly than the the words she
passed or that the the leading by
example that you watched is what
resonates with you totally and it's good
to hear because I always think like I
could be telling my kid more or doing
more but the fact that she sees her dad
at the games gets up every day and goes
to work takes care of his [ __ ]
business like that yeah you're right
that matters man it doesn't because I
don't think I think human beings are
inherently closed to being told what to
do it's like a violation over
Independence that's why I rejected
school so much
show me what to do
and I'll follow that lead if I feel like
it works for me it's how I it's how I
got through all the [ __ ] I got through I
don't even think I ever had a
conversation with my mother once about
my feelings really like ever I feel like
that would be the woman that would be
able to yeah yeah she's just like we
can't but we just don't she's hyper
secretive my mom is such a g like a
gangster she's still alive she's still
alive okay what my mom does is my mom
was a nurse and she'd quit being a nurse
because she even though we needed money
so she really did do it she got through
college and put herself in and became a
nurse became a nurse's assistant an RNA
and then she she left the job because
she felt that the doctors were over
prescribing medication and she felt it
was a violation of her principles so she
quit she gets a job assigning nurses
like for just a company
and then my mom leaves that and my mom's
full-time job today is she's a gangster
missionary so if you come to Toronto
you're a refugee you need someone to
help you out you get my mom's number she
sets you up I've come home and my
Furniture's gone from my home because
she took it and gave it to a family
somebody knew who came to Canada she
says this person needed this I'll get
you one down the road like my mom is all
about you you are only in service of
others this is my mom's way of living
out the Social Gospel as much as so many
Christians drive me crazy in the public
space certainly in politics I'm like why
don't y'all learn from my mom that's how
you live the gospel so my mom is like
yeah she's we don't agree on a lot but
she is uh I just watched her your core
values oh my God the same total matters
and I didn't need to talk about feelings
because what I knew was I got love I can
figure this out on my own not everybody
can
go do it how you have to do it how what
worked for me won't work for everybody
else but I watched I watched how to
process trauma by watching my mom do it
so then how did you implement that in
your life growing up without a dad and
being out on the streets by yourself
like what's are you a good student are
you getting in trouble are you getting
arrested are you lit you know what were
you like I have been arrested
um she didn't know until later she might
not know until somebody tells her
you're still gonna get in trouble
been there when the police have come
over I have said this come over yeah I
like their company
that did happen to be it one or two
times as a kid
no you know what man I I um I was a
terrible student I hated school I had a
teacher hit me once in school hit you on
purpose but he was right though he hit
me with a textbook and he said you're
smarter than this this is stupid these
marks suck and I said to him you know I
don't care about this but I actually
didn't I wouldn't mind that he hit me I
just thought we had that kind of
relationship where he could you know be
a [ __ ] and I was cool with it
um because I knew he had my best
interest in heart so to me those kinds
of words don't matter alone context
subject versus Target matters that's why
I love comedy that offends myself
because I understand where it's coming
from right my teachers that were pretty
tough and but I was a bad student didn't
really care about school didn't have a
plan didn't think of this for a living I
just got kicked I want to be an artist
and an architect but I got kicked out of
art class because the teacher wouldn't
let me in for no reason she's like can't
come in and I'm like but you don't even
know me did you have a look that she
didn't like were you yeah basically a
younger version what you're seeing right
now you know earrings and I'd listen to
a lot of really insane heavy metal and
punk rock and so I guess they thought I
was a trouble automatically yeah and
maybe I was maybe I was so I can own it
up to my end of that but I was forced to
graduate in Ontario I needed to get an
Arts Credit and in my school the only
other Arts Credit
was drama which was the last class I
would have ever taken I was shy I was a
[ __ ] I was never going to perform but
I took it and then I got so lucky that
the teacher who'd LED that class looked
at me and went I got you and figured out
and so like later in high school when I
got kicked out of high school I had a
teacher you got kicked out I got kicked
on high school I refused to um uh adhere
to the uniform
and also they wanted me to go to a
Catholic Retreat and me as a young kid
who's not going to any Catholic [ __ ]
was like yeah I'm not doing that and
they said well you you got to go you
can't come to class so I got suspended
and I was wearing some shoes they didn't
like so but my teacher said to me look
why don't you come to school anyway and
I'll mark you absent the office will
never know you were here but you won't
fall behind and then when it comes time
to write the exam you'll be ready and
this is what this teacher said to me I
had two other teachers he went and spoke
to them got them to agree to that
and that's why I got through high school
so the three teachers were in cahoots to
get you through High School get me
through high school and I'll tell you
man that's [ __ ] awesome the grace of
others any one of us who's successful in
this in our whatever China uh line of
work the grace of others people have no
reason to care but choose to
that like I'm hyper grateful for that
God gets me emotional I'm like yeah you
gave a [ __ ] my own mom though like what
the you giver and I'm like whoa thank
you so much because it doesn't need to
be family it just needs to be somebody
that gives a [ __ ] that's what this show
is right yeah let somebody sit there
who's watching this right now and
they're making dinner and they're alone
and or they're with somebody they don't
want to be with them they feel alone and
they're listening to you tell some
stories and the people you bring on tell
stories and for 10 minutes an hour two
hours they sit back and go I get it
we're just planting seeds in people's
brain and who knows what soil they have
in their brain and what grows but it's
just a letter who knows some kid out
there some guy a girl hears this show
and then 10 15 years on the road they do
their own it makes an impact yeah it
really matters so yeah that's so I I was
very lucky that you know my mom didn't
really know what I was we're not we're
not the kind of family that shares that
kind of details I remember my mom
telling me once uh about what we were
talking about this time that she had
cancer and we were talking about this
and I sat back and I went
when did you have cancer
foreign
two years ago
she never went through chemo she and she
got assorted and went you don't think
you should tell your son two years ago
she goes I didn't want to worry you and
I'm like man you're such an immigrant
like my mom is such an OG immigrant you
don't tell us I can't want to tell you I
had cancer I didn't want you to worry
it's the one thing yeah you tell
everybody right yeah yeah wow my mom was
she raised me to believe you don't air
your dirty laundry in public I when you
asked me to do this that is immigrants
my grandmother of all Italians they were
all the same thing don't tell anyone in
your business we grew up in a big
Italian neighbor don't tell the doctors
nothing I'm like how they gonna help me
I'm over here telling them I'm not
taking any of this [ __ ] but I'm taking
all of it they're misdiagnosing me
because I'm over here not telling them
anything totally don't sign nothing
don't sign them yeah yeah I'm like hey I
want to do this I think this is a good
Financial move my mom's like that and so
now it was minor but still it was like
you don't really would tell somebody
that but I looked at her and I just said
God you're a beauty like you're the my
mom I look at my mom and I think the
best way I can describe her is my mom is
the Wilderness and all the things you
would find in the wilderness you find in
this little blonde woman who is still
the most important person in my life and
even though we battled a lot as a kid
because I was a problem I was very
rebellious Mary Mary I call her madushka
and whenever she gives me a hard time I
call her by her first name and then I
said when you act like my manager I'll
call you by your name
um yeah so I'm just so grateful that I
had that but she didn't know any of the
stuff that was happening in my life she
still doesn't she never remarried or did
she she did later I also didn't find out
for two years get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah yeah yeah your mom said Cancer
and a second husband and then tell you
you know I found out my sister called me
and goes did you know your mom's married
yeah because that's what we say when she
does crazy [ __ ] like I'm like what do
you mean she's married yeah I was going
through the house and I found the
marriage certificate and I was like cool
funny did you know she was dating I knew
she had a guy that she really loved but
because she was super Christian she so
my mom is a really interesting woman
she'll kill me for even telling the
story because she doesn't want anybody
to know anything about her my mom is so
interested in doing things the right way
there were some people in the family
that were batting battling some health
issues and she they were planning on
announcing it at this Christmas tell
everybody we'd all be very happy but
then the family was going through some
tough times with some some elderly
people my mom didn't want to take the
light away from it didn't want to make
it about her Joy because there was some
stuff we had to deal with and she's like
I would have told I wanted to tell
everybody once we got through this so
make how do you not love that
how do you not respect that that's my
mom my mom says not about me it's not
about you it's about us all right so let
me ask you this then what's the um
what's the most disappointed your mom's
ever been in you and how did she react
yeah
you know what's funny man is I don't
know if she's ever even so I'm I'm
wondering yeah because she seems like no
matter what it is she takes it in stride
yeah I'm angry she's ever been with you
very angry my mom told me
um
if you end up in jail tonight tonight
where were you going oh oh just in any
night okay all right she told me this
many times actually don't call me
she said don't call me
um if you get arrested there's a high
likelihood you did it
so sit in jail and learn your [ __ ]
lesson she didn't swear but my mom said
don't call me like she said you need to
understand if you're going to go out
there and make big man decisions even
though I was a boy then pay the big man
price yeah so she there were a couple of
times where we would we would battle a
lot over my rebellious sort of Devil's
music thing I was listening to a lot
but a couple times we got some fights
and I would use language I'm not proud
of I was 13 but I still regret it and I
remember it and she would kick me out of
the house and I never put hands on you
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah when I was young
oh yeah yeah for sure but not like my
mom wasn't a beta area yeah but I've
taken a spoon or two to the neck over
the years you know it'll be checked yeah
if you're like that you're gonna be
checked totally and you know what you
know I got a couple of smacks but I feel
like I earned it I deserved it I
understand that it's complicated now
people will write me back and you never
did I'm like and that's cool and I get
it but it turned out fine for me
um but my mom I for my mom to lay hands
on me as a young kid I had to push her
and everybody has their breaking point
right but she didn't do it often not
often my mom didn't have to because I
just get that look in my in my mom's
eyes she pre um pre-disappointed right
so it wasn't that I did anything to
disappoint her she just laid it on me to
make sure that I wouldn't and there were
many times where I'd go out there and do
some stuff I think I was gonna do some
stuff and then that poem she put in my
head would come back and I just can't
believe you and remember that whole poem
bro I changed my I changed my whole
Behavior because that poem
I did some stuff that I'm not I was a
young kid you break a cup whatever I
won't admit anything here but I I did
stuff and I was about to do stuff and
then I that poem popped into my head and
I went home
and she had no idea that that little
poem and the way she raised me is the
difference between me making that one
choice
versus another that prisoner dead
totally that Split Decision moment that
iced tea writes about in his new book
man it's from that poem so I I actually
made it an important part of my journey
to honor my mom's commitment to me and
my sister not the way she wants but in a
way which is due right by what she
taught me
um so she'd been angry at me for sure
because I was really problematic as a
kid for sure but I always made her laugh
and she always made me laugh so we had a
good thing you know I'm super grateful
and I'm really grateful my dad left if
I'm being honest because I think if he
had stayed he was a bit of an angry guy
at the time I don't know what he's like
now but my dad was tough and
I wouldn't have turned out the way I did
if my old man had stuck around and was
if he treated me the way he treated her
I would have gone to jail so I'm
grateful that that he split and I and I
I highly encouraged him like if you want
to go just don't come back man like he
didn't there's no conflicting I mean I'm
out I made him out he made a call and
it's like cool this is over now we're
doing it this way
you know those blue suits that had like
the frilly white shirts that go with
that pastel blue it's the best suit ever
and I remember there's an episode of The
Simpsons when when Homer was dating the
country it's like one of those good
fellow suits he's like bring it back
bring it back
remember when Homer was managing Laura
Lane it was stand by your manager
episode and and he was wearing the
Colonel Tom suit he was Colonel Homer
and Bart Simpson said as much as I hate
that man right now you gotta love the
suit yeah
it's like God I love that suit say
goodbye to last year's outdated
disorganized methods of managing your
money and say hello to Rocket money the
better way to hack your finances in 2023
rocket money formerly known as true bill
is a personal finance app defines and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forget about like that streaming
service you bought to watch just one
show on or that free trial that you
never even used rocket money will
quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for the ones you don't want
rocket money makes canceling
subscriptions as easy as a click of a
button simply find the subscription you
don't want and press cancel and Rocket
money will cancel it for you no more
long hold times of customer service or
emailing back and forth over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to seven
hundred and twenty dollars a year all
right I use this personally I'm always
subscribing to Hulu or Discovery Plus or
something show time to get that free
week or whatever and then I forget to do
it next thing you know you're like holy
[ __ ] I just paid 10 months this and I
mean watch one show stop throwing your
money away cancel unwanted subscriptions
and manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com honeydew that's
rocketmoney.com honeydew rocketmoney.com
honeydew there's no quick fix for
anxiety and depression it's not finding
a new therapist star starting an
exercise routine regular meditation or a
better diet if you haven't figured it
out yet life healing and becoming a
better version of yourself is a process
it doesn't stop you don't magically
arrive but sometimes you need something
to unlock your brain a new way of
thinking about and seeing the world
maybe that thing is guided ketamine
therapy from mind Bloom mind Bloom is
the leader in at home ketamine therapy
for people looking for a new way to
treat their anxiety and depression they
combine science-backed medicine with a
guided treatment plan that is both
affordable and fast acting to begin you
take mind Bloom's online assessment and
schedule a video consult with a licensed
psychiatric clinician if approved you'll
work with mind Bloom on your specific
treatment plan and you'll be mailed a
customized kit complete with medicine a
journal and treatment materials after
only two sessions 87 percent of Mind
Bloom clients reported Improvement in
depression 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety it's time to
enter your next chapter in mental health
and well-being achieve transformational
outcomes with mind Bloom let me say this
I did six sessions count me among the 85
percent that has been helped with my
anxiety I'm telling you things don't
bother me like they did I think about
them in a new way now I don't allow
myself the future trip and freak out on
these things and I'm telling you mind
Bloom it worked for me right now mind
Bloom is offering my listeners a hundred
dollars off your first six session
program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and use promo
code honeydew at checkout go to
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that's
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew you may have heard about that
grass CBD joints flowers and tinctures
it's 100 organic hemp to chill you out
without getting you stoned to the Bone
and now you can pop in to chill with
their brand new and not to mention
delicious CBDs gummies that grass is
legal organic smokable hemp that relaxes
your body and Mellows your mind they're
100 organic pre-rolled joints and flour
are very low in THC and high in CBD so
you can enjoy the effects of CBD while
keeping a clear head they offer a
variety of products so you can Tok or
dose just the way you like from their
CBD tincture drops to the newly launched
CBD gummies and flavors like classic
Blackberry ginger good time hibiscus
lime and nighttime midnight Berry you
can chill out without getting stoned and
that grass didn't forget your furry
friends they also just released CBD dog
bones all dagrass products are federally
legal for ages 18 and over and it ships
right to your door anywhere in the U.S
so whether you're looking for a new Buzz
or a chill way to enjoy an old favorite
dagrass will leave you in a euphoric
mood right now that grass is offering my
listeners 20 off your first order when
you go to daggrass.com honeydew go to
dadgrass.com honeydew for 20 off your
first order that's daggrass.com
now let's get back to the do and look
honestly bro I don't I don't have any oh
well towards people who make tough
choices because it sucks for them too
and I know now what you know what we all
know is that they have unchecked trauma
they didn't deal with if they didn't get
to do the work yeah some people are
shitty and got to be out of the system
but a lot of this is mental health and
abandonment and anxiety and depression I
I ain't mad at people who didn't know
and also I feel sorry these days I feel
sorry because I'm like well you [ __ ]
lived your whole life without your kids
your grandkids like you don't really
have the respect you don't have that no
that your dad does not have the respect
of his children that Mom does yeah yeah
for sure and part of the reason he's got
to live with that whether it bothers
them or not that's something that man
care I'm sure you're aware of it is he
still alive he's still alive as far as I
know
um occasionally he'll like an Instagram
post of mine which is awesome which is
awesome but it does I'm actually kind of
like I'm cool he's alive but I think
part of now I'm different than I used to
be but part of the reason I didn't want
anything really to do with that with him
was I not because I had I was angry at
him I just never wanted to appear
disloyal to my mom you know and I'm like
man she's doing all the work he doesn't
get to be good dad on the weekends like
there's no bad cop good cop here she's
she's the general
and I'm here to follow the job I didn't
follow the orders I probably should have
but she's the general I'm on her side
and
as I got older I realized I don't need
sides but back then I was so loyal to my
mom sure and I'm still loyal to all the
people in my life now as a result of
that
um yeah and I'm [ __ ] devastated like
if she was on here that the trauma story
she went through my grandmother getting
into fights with Nazis and Soviet
soldiers post-war during the war and and
I'm like man the women in my life have
dealt with mega trauma I'm here just to
go ladies thank you thank you for your
service because look at how lucky we are
now because the work you did when I see
somebody honk a horn at an old lady
walking down the street I'm not prone to
violence but I want to get out there and
punch that person in the [ __ ] face
because it's like do you know what that
old woman had to deal with especially
somebody who lived in the 40s and the
50s do you know how [ __ ] hard their
life was and she's a little slow
crossing the road and you got to get to
what [ __ ] Pilates go [ __ ] yourself
yeah yeah let her take her time running
and get your Starbucks pick up yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] hate that I have a soft
spot for that too my grandma was like a
mom to me and all her sisters so I was
always raised with that you know take
care you know the Elder generation don't
be a gentleman you respect them you
[ __ ] help them you call them ask them
if they need this go get their groceries
whatever it is help them yes I'm the
same way you know one of the reasons I
think I became an interviewer and for a
living is that when I was young and my
mom couldn't afford a babysitter she
would do two things she would she'd do
temp work right A lot of times when in
between gigs she would take me to a
local library and a neighborhood called
Rex they'll throw me inside there and
tell me you're not allowed to leave she
let the Librarians know I was staying
there I'm like six right she'd say seven
eight she'd say hey can you just not let
him leave it's a tough neighborhood let
him stay here so I would just wander the
library by myself in the morning young
like a [ __ ] baby by myself reading
books I thought every the Librarians
were so attentive it's just because they
were keeping an eye on me because my old
lady asked him to she would then pick me
up for lunch
we'd have lunch she would take me down
the street same street there's a senior
citizens home there and she would
actually tell me go inside
find somebody and keep them company 100
she'd say there are people in there who
have nobody and they have lived a life
you will never live they have done
things that you will never experience
she had a friend in there she'd visit
she'd say your job is to go sit beside
somebody who has nobody and listen to
them and learn I was shy as hell and so
this is your mom like everybody should
go through a course with your mom
totally and I said this to her one day
and she's like I didn't know what I was
doing she said go take a customer
service good job
and I think now
sending a seven eight-year-old boy who
was shy into a a room filled with 70
year old men who were in World War II
because that's how long ago it was so
there's nothing that can sway me I think
because I had that love and no matter
what happens to me from here on in I'm
like I'm all right man I'm all right you
know so yeah when I saw my dad and he
didn't recognize me I looked at him and
I went this is for you not for me we had
lunch it was really nice I caught up
with what his life was and I left and I
haven't seen him since and I have no I
don't really think about it it doesn't
bother me but my ex who's one of my best
friends today
she said put the time in with them when
you can
not because you want to or you need to
but there'll be a time when he's not
around and if you ever wonder should you
have you'll have answered the question
and I thought
that's why I'll do it I mean I'm one of
those men that is so fortunate that they
were like three or four women in my life
who not that it's their job but they
helped me become a better version of
myself I didn't have that for a while
and I'm just so grateful that I was
surrounded by some unbelievable people
who
saw a young rough kid who was going to
go down the wrong path and they just
guided me and I had a couple of my uncle
was amazing taught me about music taught
me how to be a good man the man my mom
Mary taught me how to be a good man so I
got lucky that that and this is the
sphere of influence matters what are you
showing the next Generation that's why I
hate when people go on
social media and act like when they say
that stupid [ __ ] racist [ __ ] that
stupid homophobic transphobic [ __ ] that
pro-capitalist anti-poverty [ __ ] I'm
like bro you are on the wrong side of
History guide guide with strength and
love if you're going to be especially
men big masculine tough men your job is
not to fight inwards your job is to
fight the enemy that's right and the
enemy are the people that are holding
other people down and I watch these
[ __ ] malacca's online you know yeah
[ __ ] what everybody thinks I'm like I'm
like bro you're fighting the oppressed
when are you all gonna die off yeah one
of you all guys yeah like you know it's
like oh I I watch people complain about
pronouns I'm like yeah I get the
complicated nature of pronouns but do
you don't think that trans people have
put up with enough
help them
because you know who's against that
people you [ __ ] hate yeah why are you
siding with those [ __ ] on a
principle come on it's like there's a
lot of [ __ ] that I'm not entirely sure I
don't understand everything in the world
but I'm like I'm the one thing I am sure
of yeah I don't know
what the [ __ ] I don't know what the [ __ ]
but you know what I do know I know is
like you know what man the people who
are being oppressed
they're usually the ones being oppressed
so like I don't get it right every time
but I do my [ __ ] best that's what
you're supposed to do with your anger
that's what you're supposed to do with
your strength that's what you're
supposed to do with your privilege and
your platform from my point of view and
I watch a lot of malakas I'm like man
you guys are dropped the [ __ ] ball
what's interesting you say that because
the core values of a good man were
absolutely rooted in instilled in me by
my father but after he passed it's all
women that help me become a better man
yeah it's all women including even
having a child and my daughter you know
and being like yeah I still got a long
way to go but my grandmother
um Miss Sandy Sandy Patterson all right
um it's her birthday yesterday I called
her and I said that to her too no
um her name's Sandy Pat well it was
she's remarried but I knewers yeah and
it's she's like my mom her son we're
still all super tight family and I
called her yesterday and I said you know
the funny story is that when she met my
brother and I in seventh grade and her
son was in Sixth and she drove us home
from soccer practice
and we just she tells me that she's like
you don't understand like you kids just
[ __ ] on your mother and I'm driving you
home and I'm I'm thinking there's no way
in hell I'm letting my kid hang out with
these two pieces of trash you know what
I mean she goes but then we get home to
your house and I meet your mother and
I'm like I [ __ ] love this [ __ ] out of
these two little kids
yeah and she leaned in to from going
from the kit and I'm a son to her still
to this day she's 75. that's what I said
I go thank you yeah thank you for taking
this [ __ ] kid that you heard right
there and looking past my anger and my
my pain and seeing the real person in
there that that was in there and helping
me bring that out and it was all it's
almost all women that have done that for
me and you pay it forward by showing I'm
trying that to others and creating a
space where people can do that to me
it's the people who get the benefit of
all this help and forget it right that's
what drives me crazy at where you came
from forget who had a handout for you
and pulled you up yeah I remember seeing
a fight in my neighborhood like you know
a bunch of kids get around the
neighborhood and bunch of dudes getting
into a fight and I watched an older kid
drive up Park his car like don't park it
stop it Middle Road get out grab the two
kids that were fighting separated and
threw them and said [ __ ] stop it got
in his car and drove away and I thought
that's okay that's it that's good now I
hear don't put your hands on my kid that
grown-up just said [ __ ] stop it and I
and I learned from that I went oh okay
I'm learning how to now if you don't
have good influences around you it can
go the other way so I have a lot of love
for people who do the wrong thing
because how are they influenced who
raised them right maybe they didn't have
the Miss Sandy that you had you know
this is the van engelstor family who
saved my life like I didn't
what do you do if you don't have them
yeah right so I try to have a generous
Spirit sometimes I'm a scrappy person in
my heart it's hard I have to remind
myself come on bro it's okay but yeah
I'm just ever so grateful yeah I try to
only let my ego ride in the car with me
by myself with the windows up like it
doesn't go to meetings with me anymore
it doesn't even get out at the gas I
mean it's just get the [ __ ] stay the
[ __ ] in there if we can say whatever the
[ __ ] we want with these windows because
sometimes you gotta build yourself up
you gotta train your brain I get it yeah
yeah I snapped inside the car and quiet
now today I was driving here to see you
and I was listening to the radio I was
listening to news and something happened
on the news and I was just like man if
anybody heard me right now yes because
it's not the elevated version of myself
that's right yeah and I you're right but
don't let it get out the car right
that's why that's where it [ __ ] stays
let's shut the [ __ ] up and sit in here
I'll be right back
I'll be right back it's like that new uh
Nick Cage movie have you seen that well
the pig no the unbearable dude he rides
in the car with his ego oh yeah young
ego you gotta see him oh I do need to
see young Nick Cage talking to him it's
really [ __ ] funny man it's really fun
I believe like I say this all the time
too if I would go back and meet my what
I I thought was my best version of
myself at 18. I would punch myself right
in the [ __ ] face right in the face
right in the face you don't know you're
gonna [ __ ] blow this you know how you
think all this is going the universe is
gonna [ __ ] take its dick out and just
go wow right across your face you ain't
gonna see it coming no no totally
totally yeah it's amazing how I'm I'm
surprised any of us survived our teenage
years not just our era like our era
specifically wild
um but I'm I how we treated each other
what we were subject to I'm surprised
any of us arrived it to be honest with
you so what when you actually first on
your own then like your real own my you
know I was late teens or I guess it was
18 or 19 when I went to
I moved to another city across Canada to
do a radio job I got my first radio job
I had an illegal Pirate Radio station
that was a part of in Canada Toronto
weirdly enough in the shopping mall
across the street from the library and
that senior citizens home so I pulled
into that place and I'd be looking
around going this is it right I did that
for a while then I went to work in
Kelowna BC this is before I cleaned up
to I was still drinking pretty heavily
and I was partying as a young boy would
I've been clean for almost 30 years now
have you really yeah 30 years yeah but
at that point I 28 I think at that point
I was living the dream out there on my
own
broke as [ __ ]
broke as [ __ ] and I looked around I'm
like yeah I can keep living like this or
I could maybe put some effort into
getting out of this because you know I
was driving a forklift at the airport in
Toronto um
18 years old unloading airplane
canisters right for cargo companies and
it would be like 10 o'clock in the
morning and the older guys that worked
there would pull it you know the six can
six pack of beer and the [ __ ] plastic
Rings 10 a.m you know 17 18 years old
boom pull out we'd have a couple [ __ ]
beers you know then you would hear that
donut truck show up we'd go have
cigarettes we're in our construction
boots as a teenager and these guys
without saying anything I looked around
and went these guys have a life that I
don't think I can do
I don't think I can do this and a couple
guys said to me get out of here this
isn't for you right I I love that job I
I my respect for that that line of work
was Heavy it's not like I was better
than that it's just I definitely was not
better than that they were better than
me I'm like I don't think I can get up
at six in the morning every day put on
my construction boots and [ __ ] lift
heavy [ __ ] I'm just not that strong I'm
not wired for it
um and I was I just I I know we're
making pre-internet right we're making
gambling calls we were booking with
Saturdays we'd bet on the Sunday
football game we'd call local radio
stations around the US to check the
weather it's a cold game let's take the
under right yeah so we were like
gambling and stuff we were 16 17 18
years old and I'm doing this job
drinking beer driving a forklift at the
airport and I I thought nah I gotta lean
into something I gotta lean into
something and I got lucky into this
business right I saw radio as an option
and I went for it
um and I was on my own then but here's
the crazy thing about being on my own
I've been on my own for the whole time I
feel but and if still to this day don't
feel alone
I never felt alone I never felt even
though I didn't have the kind of
relationship with my family where we
would talk about feelings I never felt I
couldn't
I felt like yeah I felt like we just
didn't need to and if you do need to
holler I'll call my sister the same way
my sister and I talk a little bit more
about what I mean as far as being raised
by your mom is just sort of take care of
my business yeah I got this [ __ ] yeah
yeah my sister's so bad she's so funny
she's so tough she's so clever
um she was a single mom for a long time
too she's married to a great guy now
um but I looked at my family and I just
like yeah we got this we're together so
and all of My Success is their success
all of their success is My Success right
so even though I've been on my own
probably since the late of 18 I guess
where I was really out there working at
this I've never my first radio job I was
also driving the forklift and afternoons
I was working at a subway making
sandwiches so I was doing three jobs
just like my mom did uh volunteering at
a community radio station because this
is what adults and my family do we go to
work but no one in your family was
entertainment they were all like blue
collar or hard workers or I think
everybody in my family everybody except
for me worked at a golf club either in
maintenance or
um in uh like cleaning the kitchen or
that kind of stuff all golf there's a
there's a golf club in my old my mama's
neighborhood a private club so my
grandmother worked there and then like
any good immigrant family got all the
[ __ ] family working there everybody
worked vacuuming or whatever so when I
got into TV and I got into meeting
people who are different social stratas
I met at Country Club life people I was
like yeah yeah I had country life too we
served you
so that was the big difference right so
yeah nobody in my family was in this
business at all but and then bro I met I
guess we could talk about this on your
podcast I haven't really talked about
this I wanted to get in radio maybe when
I was 14. didn't know how to do it
I met a guy I was an expert on a TV show
just for fun I met this guy uh who is a
Corral in the extras and then he said
what do you want to do for living I said
I want to get a radio I was 14 15. he's
like oh I make a radio show I knew who
he was he was a pretty famous radio guy
in Canada
and then he's like why don't you come
over to the studio and help me make the
show I'm like cool I'd love to I was so
happy I go there he's a sexual predator
no tries to get me drunk tries to
sexually assault me really oh yeah bro
and this happened a couple of times from
these how old are you at the time 14 or
15 right how old is he 40. oh yeah 40.
so he was he was in his radio [ __ ] to
[ __ ] bring kids in them so what do
you do
um I leave I pushed him and I took off
because luckily I was Street raised
right where like I just it worked for me
that I was able to get out he identified
a vulnerable boy he identified a you
know single family he did all the work
to figure out who I was he would show up
at my house he would show up my house to
try to do [ __ ] I but I knew I knew that
was like I can't do it try to get me
drunk at 14 and using radio this is the
thing I wanted to do for a living using
radio as the thing so my whole life has
always been these [ __ ] Target we're
targets all the time right so that's why
now in my life he's like oh I have a
show it's great I have a show I get
fired I don't give a [ __ ] this is the
game life is like this right so all the
hardship that happened
it never bothered me because I was like
oh no dude real hardship happens when
those guys are out there trying to take
you right yeah big radio I I've I don't
know why but I'll tell you this I was on
a plane a few years ago
and I'm sitting there and there's a guy
beside me he's like oh he recognized me
from Canada he's like oh yeah we have a
friend in the business I said oh cool
what's his name and he mentions the
guy's name I said oh you know him right
do you have a son he said yeah
I said was that guy ever around your son
when your son was a little boy he said
yep I said you should probably talk to
your son
and again pardon me when
you just talk to your son really I could
see the color drained from his face you
know I'm like [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy wow what a way to find that totally
totally I've never done I don't I don't
name him publicly or whatever but but
I'm aware of who he is right he's still
alive he sent me a Facebook message A
bunch of years ago saying have we met
before
so when I became more well known in
Canada he's like have we met before and
I didn't respond to him but in my head
I'm like there will come a time there
will come a time when you will know have
you ever crossed paths never saw wow but
I found out later when I so I ended up
working at a radio station that he used
to work at and I found out that he did
this to all kinds of little boys when he
was coming up and I'm like none of you
[ __ ] stopped them like none of
you stopped them that's another DJ you
just playing music man yeah totally so I
grew up believing that you were always
in danger and the system was never there
for you the police weren't there for you
most Elders weren't there for you the
companies weren't there for you the
church wasn't there for you the school
wasn't there for you so I grew up
believing that systems are not there for
you but people individually can be
so that's why when the world's on fire
now
I'm not
freaked out by it because I'm never
people yeah and I never expected it to
be Joey Diaz has a great thing you know
you don't need a whole bunch of
[ __ ] that three months three
bad [ __ ] take over a country
yeah I got my bad [ __ ] I got my
bad [ __ ] it's one of the
greatest [ __ ] lines
three bad [ __ ]
I love it and it's true it is that's
true in our industry I'm sure you
cross-path in comedy like there's a lot
of [ __ ] Bad Dudes out there man and I
was just lucky to have experienced it
young enough and was given the tools to
handle it the streets gave me the tools
right my mom taught me how to process it
that's what I figured the street taught
me how to handle it in the moment
my mom taught me how to handle the after
effects she doesn't know about this by
the way if my mom doesn't have that cell
phone doesn't have the internet oh
really she probably won't even know
um but
she has no idea that this happened to me
when I was a kid most people don't but
it I never let those [ __ ] sway me
like those [ __ ] are never gonna get
my way I'm on my path man and I never
thought I was promised a clear path
there will always be obstacles there
will always be people out there in your
way sometimes they're doing it on
purpose and sometimes they're not either
is irrelevant to me right I'm on my
[ __ ] path
um yeah that radio guy man he did it to
a lot of [ __ ] kids and that radio
station and that industry in Toronto
protected him for years as it blows me
away that anybody would protect someone
like that yeah for whatever job even if
you're the president because what are
most people right dude cowards yeah most
people are [ __ ] cowards yeah and I
won't be one I probably was when I was
younger sure I mean you gotta learn how
to not be something you know I was
scared a lot when I'm too younger for
sure now I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I
remember leaving my house every day for
school walking to school thinking if I
saw a group of boys across the street
I'm getting beat up today like it was
that kind of neighborhood so my fear
receptors were constantly moving now I
have almost no fear I'll go to war zone
is you know for work and I don't have
fear I'm not stupid about it but I don't
have the same kind of fear I have no
anxiety about any of this because I grew
up like really learning how to manage it
early I'm super grateful for that you
know
and you did have a great mom the best
and a great Foundation core values and
honesty
the neighborhood I lived in was a place
called Malton if you ever you haven't
been Toronto yet but when people land in
Toronto they land at that airport that's
the neighborhood I grew up in by the
airport right there yeah I could walk to
the airport
um and I remember almost getting
arrested in Pakistan so my
neighborhood's really tough
um I was in Pakistan 10 years ago but
plus during the war and I was about to
get arrested by the secret police I was
filming something for journalism they
didn't want me to film it and I was
trying I was fighting the cop just to
stall so my camera operator could get
the [ __ ] disc out of the camera so
and and leave so it wouldn't get
confiscated and I'm escalating the fight
and I realize I'm about to get arrested
but I'm just doing it to give the camera
guy time this car stops in the middle of
Lahore a busy City and a busy Port of
Pakistan this car stops I'd never been
there before woman gets out of the car
and she yells strombo nah bro and I'm
like what and the cop goes what she says
I'm from Malton my neighborhood and went
mountain and I walked up to her and the
cop just left
I don't know who she was she so saved me
that's an angel right now my
neighborhood my neighbor got my back you
know
so I'm grateful for that man that runs
deep that is so [ __ ] timing too
Pakistan during the war she's like I'm
from Malton I'm like my neighborhood
just saved my life I'm down 100 how do
you not love that neighborhood forever
totally did my heart forever man that
crazy how life comes when you stick
around if you just stick around for life
so much weird fun different [ __ ] comes
back into play later it's kind of
[ __ ] wild gotta be open you gotta be
friendly you gotta be kind and you gotta
be ready that's it
open Friendly ready and kind man these
are the only things that really [ __ ]
matter to me because I go to Burning Man
every year like your buddy Harlan I love
Harlan I go to burning man I see a whole
bunch of people who don't participate in
the [ __ ] Capital system we live in
they don't do the job [ __ ] they're happy
we're out here [ __ ] slugging it out
every day trying to get people we don't
know shooting at each other in traffic
yeah yeah right yeah and we're trying to
get people we don't know to like our
[ __ ] posts and retweet our [ __ ] and
we're like what the [ __ ] are we doing
what is this what is this we don't have
to do this we choose to and so I I I
reframed myself a long time ago which is
man I'm doing this because I want to do
this I don't do this because I need to
do this anymore right and that was I
took the preciousness out of the game
craft to me now this is like I love the
craft I love meeting you I love
listening to what you said on your I
love watching your stories that people
talk about here that's what I love to do
this isn't precious to me this is just a
human experience and that's what's I I
my name my neighborhood and my family
prepared me for that in the biggest way
man that's [ __ ] great
all right so I want to ask you this now
we've talked about everything we've
talked about going back uh advice you
would give to your 16 year old self
you know I
I I would tell myself when I was 16
um
you're doing it like you've got this
already
you've got this and doesn't matter what
happens
you'll be okay like you will be okay
because when I'm 16 I'm sitting there
thinking I have no career path I have no
real dreams I have no real vision for
any of this stuff I want to be a
filmmaker but I don't how do you do that
right and I I would come back to myself
and I would say dude
steady
steady it isn't going to go your way all
the time
but just stay on this path because I
would have taught myself then that the
achievement isn't the issue
the doing it is the thing that's the
[ __ ] goal that's what I didn't know I
didn't know when I was 16 when I was 16
I had to make something got to do it
it's like the thing like look end result
doesn't matter the end result doesn't
[ __ ] matter I also would have told
myself which games I should have bet on
I would have bet on [ __ ] Buster
Douglas over Mike Tyson
because I I lost money on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] not much but I would have told me
no I wouldn't I honestly would have told
myself that the journey is actually the
thing it is and I probably would have
taught myself to meditate if I'm being
real talk I would have said um be
healthy quit drinking earlier
um do that kind of [ __ ] like I quit
drinking early but I said quit drinking
earlier
um having fun the other thing I would
have taught myself is you know right
away if your friends are toxic
you know right away for friends with
toxic
and while I do think it's important
Jasmine one of my best friends taught me
this throwaway Behavior not people
but I would have I would have learned uh
earlier what Behavior to avoid I didn't
know that [ __ ] because I thought you had
to like stick it out and make it work
right you don't have to make it work you
don't no and it's not self-care it's
just like this is you're on your trip
bro yeah I'm going elsewhere yeah I
would have learned that a little bit
earlier I would have liked to learn that
a little bit earlier dude thank you for
coming on this is a great episode I
really appreciate you taking time please
again plug promote everything you'd like
man I'm on Apple music every day and
apple music kids I love sharing music
and playing stories I get to play
there's 100 million songs in the Apple
music world so I get to play them all
they let me do my thing they trust us
our team is incredible
uh they've been great Partners in it
they honestly just said tell stories
they value storytelling and they let me
tell some stories and play some great
songs so that's what every day on Apple
music kids you can find it strombo or
just follow me on social media I'll be
there all right thank you brother I
really do appreciate you coming on
um and thank you all as well
um ryansickler.com Ryan Cyclone all
social media we will talk to you all
next week
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]